[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever
we want [ __ ] tim is back i'm back
thank you for coming back i'm back and
my cholesterol is high i just found out
bro really yeah dude what are you eating
well look i hadn't been to the doc i
haven't had a real checkup in like 10
years
okay oh yeah like a physical like a
physical grab your balls and
go like i wish what doctor are you
if that was the case i would win every
year but i went to a doctor and apps are
there
i paid her a lot of money nah it's like
50 bucks
50 bucks yeah that's cheap cheaper there
you're thinking of
um nah i hadn't if anything i got blood
work a few years ago when i was about to
get on some acne medication and that
lady told me
my cholesterol was kind of at the
borderline oh wow like whatever
well she was like look it's not high but
from where it's where it is it it's it's
it's there you know what i'm saying and
so i had my official checkup
and everything else is fine all the
blood works fine except she's like yeah
your your bad cholesterol well i'm
looking at the [ __ ] and it's like it's
definitely higher
so she was like just lay off red meats
uh butter
cheese which i was already avoiding like
fatty foods i love like a fatty steak i
love like pork belly
um you know i love like a nice like
buttery situation so
i'm like just the good stuff all the
best i wonder if you can eat those
things if you did
cardiovascular exercise oh and she said
to work out more
because i heard that that was the thing
because there's a lot of skinny people
that can get high cholesterols too yeah
but then it's because i like the blood
it's getting like a
corroded right yeah i don't do a lot of
cardio usually so
that's because it sucks it's stupid it
sucks ass i don't like it either but
there's fun cardio though i did boxing
like [ __ ] paddle party you just
paddle a little
like this that's true that's that's it
and it doesn't see you and you're like
oh that [ __ ] trying to bite me
and then you keep going or there's like
biking you're just biking
that's true or like more sports act it
out oh skateboarding you're
skateboarding
you're [ __ ] scootery badminton i
don't know about batman
that's very true it's very chill very
strong you do it
do you batman no i i took boxing lessons
for like a few weeks and that was really
fun
uh got me all sweaty and and and fun how
come you stopped it
oh because the guy i liked my trainer he
moved to new york
never mind that's his fault you should
join bart yeah his training
fine no you shouldn't it's in your dna
too your time when he says that
he means he doesn't want to do it all
right
i don't know i i have so much fun with
like
these i don't know it's not what are
they called in
endured sports or right high intensity i
don't know if they're
like how we all look towards the bar
like yes right what does that mean i'm
still waiting for him to describe what
he likes
i don't know like mountain biking
skateboarding
playing everywhere spartan race those
are just called f
well they're called fun times right guys
let's all play let's let's all play
kickball
every week that's fun that would be so
fun i'm just playing baseball man
baseball was so funny
with that red ball game do you think
they're going to
shame us for not quarantining at the
park
no that's cool we're all going to be
separate like that's far you mean social
distancing yeah
i'm playing i'm playing um social
distance sports i'm not playing
like sports that can require a team like
basketball
what we should do is we will hire a
karen and then when a karen comes to
break up her [ __ ] she's like oh no no
i'm already here yelling at them and
then like oh that's her territory we got
a referee of it
yeah funny that's a good idea that is a
good idea you should hire a parent
yeah i'm stealing that i'm stealing it
premeditated karen so when another karen
tries to come and be like i got this one
she's like no no i'm already yelling at
them come on
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] and she's like no
[ __ ] i saw them doing this you weren't
doing a good job enough and she's like
wow well i guess we gotta do it perfect
then wait wait what happens then
when someone comes and wants to rescue
you from the karen
and they're attacking your hired karen i
don't know i'm just eating popcorn i'm
like oh
[Laughter]
what do you call that anti-karen yeah
uh uh uh what do you call it a uh
something citizen like a supportive
citizen a caring eater dude
karen e caranita
[Laughter]
you know what's crazy so in the marines
i was you get blood tests
every single year because you had a
physical and uh during that time i was
super into bodybuilding and i was like
bulking like a [ __ ] and i wasn't
doing cardio
and but in my mind since i was lifting
so much weight i thought i was healthy
right i got my blood work and i also had
high cholesterol
and i'm like what the [ __ ] i go to the
gym like six times a week
did you feel unhealthy i did it i felt
and i was like oh [ __ ] cardio is
important
you know this lady i worked with for a
very short amount of time
at one hospital that worked out for a
very short amount of time
she said she was psychic she read my
palm and she said i was going to die of
a heart attack
what [ __ ] that's specifically cut back
on that cheese and ranch on those tiny
tacos you eat a jack in a box
they're so good they're so good they're
tiny tacos are fire they're so good
you said you're gonna have a heart
attack she said i'm gonna have three i
think
oh you're gonna have three heart attacks
something like that but she said that i
was gonna have one
first well how many have you had so far
zero still got a lot of time to go
but did you get tested for cholesterols
so i did back in two thousand
and two eleven
oh you're fine then that's nine years
ago yeah every nine years damn you like
me
no i have had a physical but they didn't
go through the thing
the way the other time did because at
that time it was through the hospital
where i was working at
um but anyway she did say i was gonna
have a heart attack she also did
say that when i was going to get married
it was going to be forever so you can't
divorce me
you believe everything she says you
should do it just in spite
of it wrong get her off get divorced and
be like so that means i'm not going to
get up
i i am so so okay with the divorce if
it's going to save your life i'm okay
with dying
i need you guys to go to save
her to save tiff right you go to vegas
get divorced
[Laughter]
so you can get remarried again no but
she said i was gonna stay with the guy
that i married forever so then that's
not
the loophole there oh we have to break
up all right what do you do is like
you you you get divorced in uh vegas elf
is the force and then you get
you get married okay yeah you get
married to a guy there and then divorce
him and then get back
with him and then you prove her wrong
yeah it's okay i'm okay with dying from
a heart attack wait she said you're
gonna die or just you didn't have a
heart attack no she's
three of them i'm gonna have like three
i forgot it was two or three
but multiple and i'm not gonna die from
the first one and i'm gonna die
from either the second or the third i
don't know and i'm gonna die like around
like 60ish 50s
a long time okay we have 20 20 seconds
early dude
it sucks pretty bad can you please
change the timeline i know right just
divorce casey and like we'll just see
what happens
yeah yeah okay how about you divorce
nikki because you guys are very clear i
have a psychic television
you you you gave us the rules i did it
because i forgot to mention
she said you're going to meet a couple
names sticky
hang on okay i'm listening that's very
specific
but look she didn't say you had to break
up you guys can get divorced legally
and still stay together oh divorce will
break
the [ __ ] chain yeah true yeah i've
accepted my fate it's okay we don't have
to divorce i could die from a heart
attack it's all right
from at 50 to 60 though that's so oh
that's so young
i've ever seen six weeks ever since i
was in the 70s and 80s since i was a
child i had always had this intuition
feeling that i'm gonna die when i'm
really young so i feel like i can't
avoid it
it's okay that's not that young though
that's pretty young
it's not young enough to like be
remembered forever and [ __ ] yeah that's
not jimmy
i do not want to be remembered forever i
know um
a psychic told my mom have i told you
sorry before probably probably
a psychic told my mom well it was a
masseuse
psychic back when i was like five years
old that's a good deal
she doesn't tell your fortune while
she's [ __ ] rubbing your back that's
why
oh yeah rubbing my mom's back and then
she was like she i met her she grabbed
my arm she was rubbing my arm and she
was like oh he's gonna
she's he's gonna get into a big car
accident um when he's like
15 or some [ __ ] like that and she said
that to me and i was like and i remember
thinking
impossible i'm gonna be famous there's
no way i'm gonna be a car accident right
and then
it wasn't until i was 16 that i
remembered oh [ __ ] i totaled the car
last year
that just like that psychic said but i
didn't get hurt but i just i got into a
big car accident
but i i didn't get hurt and i was like
oh [ __ ] she was right 15 is very precise
yeah yeah cause all i remember go back
to
i don't know if it's the same lady but a
a psychic also told my mom that next
year
was going to be one of my like most
popping years like 2021
yeah 2021 you a lot next year because i
want some of that to rub off yeah bro
let's
do it let's do it me too let's we'll see
it let's see you're the reason why
it's so good oh that'd be cool
[Laughter]
this moment right here started the the
[ __ ] effect
can you set the standard for us what
would be a popping year in timmy's
trainings
a popping year for me she said the words
popping here
yeah she said pop in here that's what
she said yeah what would be great is if
i got a part in either like a
network show or a your own show that's
popping you know what
yeah sure you have that yeah or or a
a big part in a movie that would be
great that's cool
or a baby or that we'll see
babies look cool i mean it's whatever i
could do that any time i wanted
not that popping that's in my control oh
it is popping though
our sponsor feels hey you know um so
i've been mountain biking a lot right
guys
like and sometimes you get some anxiety
going downhill
like i haven't had this kind of anxiety
in quite some time
and i realize i like adrenaline anxiety
like it's a good [ __ ] feeling
isn't it addicting yes because it's like
it's almost like controlled
rollercoasterisms right
and then you go home and it's like
midnight
and you're like i gotta wake up tomorrow
but i'm still feeling this heart
beating i'm trying to listen to some
meditation and chants and [ __ ] and
nothing's working
but feels hooked me up with some oils
and [ __ ] i just put a few drops on my
tongue
and in a few minutes i just let it kick
in and before you know it i'm in a
different mind state i can go to sleep
what's in fields
cbd yeah yeah cbd it's all the good
premium it keeps your head clear helps
you feel your best
cbd proven to greatly reduce anxiety
pain and sleeplessness
so if you want to feel your best every
day it can help you too become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order
plus free shipping that's f e a l s
dot com off the record to become a
member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping
you know what i realized that if i don't
have a little bit of adrenaline
in my life i don't feel happy you have
to have that risk
yeah i think that quarantine was cool
and then like um after a while like i'm
well rested and it gets to the point of
what's the meaning of life there's no
excitement there's nothing going on
and i think that's why i am i engage in
sometimes risky behavior
because it makes me feel alive and happy
that's why you were shredding outside
shred dude that's why he has that
hairstyle right now he's on a skateboard
shredding by the way shredding
shredding oh damn i fell yesterday in
front of the neighbors and they laughed
at me
your hair is long wait you fell
yesterday
oh [ __ ] at the uh i the neighbor down
there
i did a jo i did a ali and i fell off of
the
curve all the eggs so just to jump no i
don't that's what i'm practicing right
now
yeah and um um that's tight this is the
hair you don't like seeing me
i hate that i know i hate it too i
really hate it too
i go to bed i'm like all right we're
gonna have some sex tonight but i have
this
i gotta take off my hat you know and
then she's like
you don't like k-pop casey he leans in
he kisses me i'm like
yeah the forehand face fall on you k-pop
casey that's k-pop case no
oh my god i hate it so much no even
seeing myself right here it's like no i
hate it too
you got to be headband casey headband
hey oh i do have a head i wear a
headband at home
oh yeah because every time so okay
naturally let your hair fall
like just like that's what happens right
so then disgusting and then do it the
other way
no no like how you usually do it oh yeah
you look like an industrial revolution
then like just kind of just a little bit
move your head just a little bit
like some of it falls on the side right
like that right here and then even that
little
tiny piece that falls creates yeah
immediately can i just say you're a
[ __ ] blast you're a riot you're fun
what if casey does this and he's all
like i got handlebars from when i eat
your [ __ ] oh yeah the pigtails because
the guys think pigtails were like
no i'll just grab the whole picture
that's it that's all you like i don't
want [ __ ] little handlebars that's
true
like this one oh
[Laughter]
no they have sex casey is the one with
messy hair
[Laughter]
that was so good put mine up in a
ponytail and i'm good to go let's go
yeah but i don't know why it's just so
repulsive tonight
i just can't do it tiff you're so fun
you're so
it's so awesome talking oh this is such
exciting he has this [ __ ] too i know
what's my [ __ ]
you don't like cankles i don't like
ankles you got cankles i'm glad you
don't have cancer
no no like when we travel and like i go
up on the plane and i come down like the
pressure
difference or whatever my ankles end up
swelling oh but he's still got power how
the [ __ ] does that
happen casey's not gonna be like all
right baby let's [ __ ] and then he sees
your candle seems to be like
oh never mind what you got marshmallow
ankles
nah he also [ __ ] after she's like
she was disappointed she's like he'd
still [ __ ] me
oh she had standards about it
but yeah i mean i don't know so then
like i'd be like
a headband or head or something what do
you prefer headband or hat
you should get a headband with a little
[ __ ] buddy
the bunny ears like a cat ears a cat
ears headband
those are so cute what if casey had that
style oh yeah this is sexy man
this is sexy hey any ladies want
handlebars here you go
it's like you want to ride a [ __ ]
scooter
it's not quite a motorcycle yet but i'm
working on it okay
vesper
stark or whatever where i'm like no
[ __ ] way like the hair
drops and you're like oh pussy's dried
up yeah yeah it really is i can't help
it
it's okay it's okay it's funny at least
it's pretty funny
i think we all have something like that
though right right i can't i can't think
of mine right now
we were in
i'm talking about before you're even in
smash mode because i'm not turned on at
this point when i'm like no no because
sometimes i mean it'll
happen okay you're like my [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't care at that point
but i'm talking about like even before
getting turned on and then i see
the bowl cut thing happen i'm like it
can't even get turned off
i don't think anything would kill my
boner except yeah
like a disgusting like odor or like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
even dookie wouldn't dooky would really
i think dookie would have
she could wipe her ass though you into
like scat porn and
i'm not into that that's what that's
called
i feel like i found out this before yeah
it came mostly from the south scat porn
oh my god i'm the jazzer yeah yeah wait
somebody
if you're doing like doggy style and
then
all of a sudden something happens an
accident but you're in her
in her vagina but then like all of a
sudden some [ __ ] like you get showered
with
that's a funny stuff i don't think so i
mean there's times where like
we're doing doggy style and i don't know
if she got too relaxed or something
she farted yeah like she didn't fart but
it was like a
like she puffed on a cigar from the back
end
[Laughter]
whoa what's that smell and i [ __ ]
dodge it
wait was it like a queef or was it a
fart i don't know
something funky came out
no guy you avoid the green clouds
no man cares when you hear the fart
noise because you assume it's a queef
are you to do a swimming squid yeah yeah
i don't know if guys
it can't get turned off that easily once
they're turned on yeah
it depends because there's some things
that can just happen like sometimes
you ever like [ __ ] bent your dick in
half kind of all like pain
pain yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought you
were gonna say have your first swung
your wife over and twitter on a knife
i have done that actually he probably
kept going like are you okay
are you i thought about it i thought
about it but she hit the nightstand hard
oh [ __ ] so i kind of knew his time out
that's a big accident
yeah i am sorry no no no no
it's funny here the it's funny because
she's okay so
it's all like if she had like a [ __ ]
dresser stuck in her head for the rest
of her life then yeah it would be a
little [ __ ] up
i'm trying to think if i've ever ran
into a situation that like
turned me off mid mid canoodling you
know and i
can't really i mean i've heard of a
situation where like this guy was going
down on this girl
and then like he just went like this and
it was tissue paper
and that was that's i've been there it's
happened it's been devastating to the
girl
but the guy didn't care he kept going no
she saw that and she was like oh [ __ ]
yeah as a man i've been done there um
uh and and this isn't about my wife but
this
like in the past where it's like you you
see a little bit of
toilet paper like and you're like oh oh
he's kind of she's cute
yeah you're like oh she's trying she
kind of like she had a crumb on her lip
you just move it aside
yeah exactly [ __ ] kiss her man it
happens you pee
you wipe it
whatever it takes to get that [ __ ] what
if you go down there
and then right about to eat it out and
you're like why does it smell like
cigarettes down here
ee she's been doing a smoke
[ __ ] smoke show yeah was that like just
not a girlfriend i was it was a carnie
it was a carnage
that doesn't sound like it happens stay
away from the carnies
no have you ever you know you know when
girls queef like when you're having sex
isn't it interesting how we as guys
immediately go like oh no it's okay baby
i know it's a quiz
oh that's worse and that wasn't that bad
you just ignore it
you have to ignore it
[Laughter]
there's one
[Laughter]
she's like i've already done so many
clean shots i'm like
oh picture using like the the beer bogs
to do that [ __ ]
oh no i got
[Music]
you